hey everyone
well i mean this is definitely a new
approach we got the the tesla
drive-in movie theater basically um
it's good to see everyone it's a little
hard to read the room
uh with everyone being in cars but it's
uh
it's the only way we could do it so
hopefully it's cool and hopefully you
can hear me can you guys hear me okay
all right great all right well thanks
for coming
um i think it's been it's been an
incredible year
um and uh i'd like to thank you for your
support
uh through uh you know tough times good
times it's been great i really
appreciate everyone who's
put their heart and money into tesla and
uh
you know i think it's worked out pretty
well this has been a good year
and i think there's many good years to
come
so i'll go through the uh the sort of
the shareholder presentation i think
fairly quickly because
the the sort of real main event here is
battery day
and and really i'm i'm just going
through a recap of of what's
happened over the past year or so
um i think starting from uh
you know in terms of our ability to
create a factory
uh the uh you know huge kudos to the
tesla shanghai team for being able to go
from
literally a dirt pile to volume
production in
in 15 months it's like damn yeah
um
so and i think something that's quite
that's
really quite noteworthy here is tesla is
the only foreign manufacturer to have
100 owned factory in china
so this is often uh uh not well
understood or not appreciated but
to have uh the only 100 owned foreign
you know foreign factory in china is is
a really big deal
um and uh it's it's paying huge
dividends here
so uh we really wouldn't have the
results that
we have had this year without the the uh
great efforts of the tesla china team so
i'm super appreciative of that
and we'll see the the shanghai factory
continue to scale
uh quite a bit from where it is right
now i think we
really could expect that to be over time
a factory that produces over a million
vehicles a year
yeah it's cool
so let's see so we also reached in the
past year volume production of the model
y and this was the smoothest launch that
we've ever had
so i think we're we're definitely
getting better at new vehicle
launches and building factories and
scaling production
i as you've heard me say before
it's the hardest thing is scaling
production
especially over new technology it's
insanely difficult
uh making a prototype is is relatively
easy
and if i think like what is the real
achievement of tesla in in sort of car
company terms
it's like it wasn't making sort of
exciting prototypes
uh it was that tesla was really the
first company
in about a century in the us the first
u.s company in the us to reach
volume production uh and
be sustainably profitable like the the
crazy thing is this this has really not
happened in a hundred years
that's the that's the actual super hard
part
um and we now have four vehicles
in volume production s3 xy
so also the toughest joke uh i think
maybe ever
um there was a very difficult joke to
make um
so we also introduced the lowest cost
solar in the u.s
uh it's only a dollar forty nine or what
um and we really just
simplified the whole chain of the whole
value chain
um so reduced sales and advertising um
it got rid of a bunch of unnecessary
costs and really uh
are just relying upon the fact that it
is it's it's just the lowest cost most
efficient solar in the u.s
uh providing both uh retrofit and the
solar glass roof
uh which i think is a really great
product a hard product to make work
that it will be a major product line in
the future
and uh we also got four consecutive
quarters of of gap profitability which
is
was was very difficult yeah
so and certainly a testament to the the
hard work of people at tesla
i mean to to do this in extremely
difficult times against
a wide range of adverse circumstances uh
was
uh insanely hard but we got it done
so and i think we've the future is
looking
like i think very promising uh from a
sort of an annual profitability
standpoint so
um in order to achieve
in order to to sort of do well
financially
you really need economies of scale and
you need ideally the best technology and
i think we
we had the best technology for a while
but now we are also achieving
economies of scale so and we're also
rapidly improving autonomy which is um a
massive value add to each car
so you know i think the the value of
tesla is going to be
like total just on the vehicle side
total vehicles produced
times the value of autonomy that's
that's a way to think about the future
value of tesla
we also have consistent free cash flow
generation uh this is really important
for
growth uh and a key element here is
tightening up the time from when
a car is ordered to when it is built and
delivered
um so for a company that is growing
rapidly
it's extremely important to tighten the
supply chain and to
to have from when from when parts arrive
put it into a car very quickly and
deliver the car very quickly to the
customer
and if if you can do that inside the the
sort of your
kind of payables timeline then the
faster you grow
the more cash you have or conversely if
you're unable to do it within your your
payables timeline
uh the faster you grow the less money
you'll have which is obviously bad
um it's for capital intensive situation
so just tightening up
and having the parts move very quickly
uh to the factory put in a car get it to
a customer
makes a massive difference to cash flow
generation and
i mean that's why it's extremely
important to have a factory
uh in each continent because if you
don't at least have a factory in the
continent
it is impossible to achieve this so
having a factory in china
that's able to serve china and then uh
you know soon
uh many many many other countries in the
region
will be uh key to us
tightening that uh that total sort of
chain of cash flow and and getting it
essentially the faster we grow more cash
this is really important
that's also why it's important to have a
giga berlin complete
because then we'll have a factory in
china factory
factory in the us and soon a second
factory in the u.s in austin
um and a factory in europe um
and and i mean even if you if for for
the for giga texas in austin
even if we had exactly the same classes
in california it would still
be advantageous to to do it there
because
it's roughly two-thirds of the way
across the u.s so
in terms of delivering cars to the
central us and to the east coast
it's far it's just faster costs less um
and um
it fundamentally improves our economics
so i think this is
also maybe something that's not fully
appreciated of just how important it is
to have
a factory at least on the continent or
reasonably close
to where the end customers is so you can
tighten that that whole chain
uh industry performance uh we've um
you know while the rest of industry has
gone down uh tesla has gone up
um i think this speaks to thanks
um and so i'd like to thank all the
customers for for taking a chance on
tesla
and and buying our product and uh really
hope you're enjoying it um
this is really you know our sales as l
was saying really grow by word of mouth
so this is really i think a very pure uh
you know it's very pure in the sense
that it's like it's it's growing on the
basis of
of existing owners recommending it to
other to
to new customers this is really i think
a good way to grow um
so um and then in 2019 we had
50 growth and i think we'll do
really pretty well in 2020 um
probably somewhere between 30 to 40
percent growth
despite uh a lot of very difficult
circumstances
um i mean there's so many you know
pandemic wildfires
it is like a whole bunch of difficult
uh production issues um but thanks to
the hard work of the taser team
and a lot of innovative approaches to
overcoming
issues we're able to still see
significant growth in one of the most
difficult in fact i say probably
the most difficult year of tesla's
existence
so and we also published our extended
impact report um
yeah tesla we we try very hard to do the
right thing
um if what i think does not happen is
just because we we maybe made a mistake
or we're we're
aware of it but we we always try to do
the right thing as to the best of our
ability
and uh and then we published the
extended impact report to
show you know just a sort of a
self-examination of
okay what are we doing right what are we
doing wrong uh what can we do better in
the future
um you know we're definitely trying to
accomplish the most good and so
you know if we if we occasionally make a
mistake we work quickly to
fix it and do the right thing
so it's worth looking at like the
average like average cycle emissions in
the us
and just how how much better a tesla is
than an electric car
than any other uh than any kind of
gasoline car
and uh what we'll talk about in the
battery day is also just how much the
the grids around the world and actually
especially in the u.s
are greening um it's it's actually much
faster than i think people realize
uh the us is moving towards sustainable
energy and so as we move more and more
to sustainable energy then
effectively you end up building the the
solar factories and the
uh the uh car factories themselves with
with solar um over time you do or with
sustainable energy over time you'll even
mine with sustainable energy
and eventually it will it will get to an
effective emissions of zero
so that's that's that's where things
will end up
so um we also have safety at the core of
our design uh
the tesla cars are the safest cars uh
ever designed
we have the lowest probability of injury
of any cars uh ever tested by the us
government and that's just passive
safety when you add
uh active safety into that uh it's even
better
uh so um you know it's it's really
if you you know if safety is important
to you which obviously
you know it is uh the the safest car you
could drive is a tesla
so um you know i think people sometimes
some people aren't aware of this but
it's really safety is paramount it is
actually the number one design
objective when we build the tesla's
safety
um our factories are also becoming safer
and if you look at the
sort of accidents per vehicle total
vehicle made it's
dramatically better than in the past and
uh it's already better than industry
average and
we're confident we can get it to the
best in the in the auto industry
autopilot functionality continues to
improve um and you can see it in the you
know the
the the safety report that we publish
every quarter um it's just getting
better and better
uh the us average for collisions is um
you know at roughly 2.1 per million
miles
and with autopilot engaged it's 0.3
i mean this is a profound difference
really
massive and this will get even better so
we're confident that over time we can
get the
probability of of an accident especially
the probability of of injury
uh to uh ten times better than the
than the uh industry average like in
order magnitude better so
that's just a lot of life saved and a
lot of injuries avoided
so that's a you know a huge priority for
us
um and um you know autopilot front
uh i think it's kind of hard for people
to judge the progress
of autopilot um like i'm
i'm driving i i as a matter of course
i've always done this i drive the
the bleeding edge alpha build of
autopilot and
so so i sort of have insight into what
is going on
um and um you know
previously about a couple years ago we
were kind of stuck in a local maximum
so we were improving but like the the
improvements kind of
started tailing off and not and just not
getting where they needed to be
we were quite cooler scared still
getting trapped in a local maximum
and so we had to do a fundamental
rewrite of the entire autopilot software
stack
and and all of the labeling software as
well
so we're now um labeling
in 3d uh video so
this is hugely different from the
previously where we were labeling
essentially a bunch of single images
from the eight cameras and they would be
labeled um at different times by
different people
and some of the the labels you literally
can't tell what it is you're labeling
um so it basically made it
sort of in some cases impossible to
label um and the labels had
a lot of errors now with our new
labeling tools
uh we label it in video so we actually
label entire
video segments and the system so so you
get
basically a surround video uh thing to
label and
uh with with the surround video and
and with time so it's now it's now
taking all amazon cameras simultaneously
and and looking at how the images change
over time
and labeling that and then the
sophistication of the neural nets in the
car and the overall logic in the car has
improved dramatically
um i think we will hopefully release
a private beta of of autopilot of the
full self-driving version of autopilot
in i think a month or so uh
and then people will really uh
understand just the magnitude of the
change it's profound
um so
yeah um anyway so
you'll see it's just like a hell of a
step change but because we had to
rewrite everything
labeling software the just the entire
code base
um it took it took us quite a while um
and the the sort of new sort of a cool
of like 4d
in in the sense that it's uh three
dimensions plus time
um uh it just it's just taken us a while
to rewrite everything
um and so you know you'll see what it's
like it's going to be
it's amazing um yeah
it's just it's clearly going to work
um you know tesla core competencies
we've got engineering
obviously um also manufacturing i think
manufacturing is uh
under-appreciated in general um and
uh and the the difficulty of designing
the machine that makes the machine
is vastly hotter than the machine itself
so
you know the the designing like making a
model 3 or
model y or cyber truck prototype is is
really quite trivial
compared to designing the factory that
makes it
especially if you're if it's new
technology and you want to use new
manufacturing methods
um it's just at least
10 to 100 times harder to do the factory
than the prototype
and that's why you see a lot of
companies out there or startups they'll
they'll bring out a prototype but they
they just can't
get it over the hump for um for
manufacturing because manufacturing
of new technology especially is the
hardest thing by far
um you know like basically the prototype
is somewhat it is
at best ten percent of the difficulty
and probably closer to one percent
uh and then software uh tesla is both a
hardware and a software company
so um a huge percentage of our engineers
are actually software engineers
and you can think of our car as kind of
like a laptop on wheels
um and so software is incredibly
important
uh and so not just actually not not just
in the in the car but also in the in the
factory
so this the factory software is
extremely important
um just software in general these i mean
these are fundamental these are the
three critical areas that um are needed
to
make for an awesome company
so yeah
so we have um now we'll soon have
three factor three new factories
incremental on well we have one already
um
on three different continents uh
shanghai we're expanding the shanghai
with the second phase
um berlin is making rapid progress um
and
texas is making even faster progress so
um
you know with each factory what we're
trying to do is also improve the
manufacturing technology so
it's um you know in some cases like the
model y made
made in berlin might look the same but
it actually is made in a much more
efficient way
and uh yeah i'll we'll talk about that
later in the battery
uh presentation yeah
it looked launched mega pack it's a
three megawatt hours all in one energy
storage solution
so it's been it's been great overall
um yeah all right
uh and i think that's basically it
right all right thank you
all right well uh thanks everyone uh for
coming and
we're back in a little bit to uh go
through the battery stuff and
there's a little bit more in addition to
the battery stuff we got a little few
extras
as well so i think you'll really like
what we have to say on batteries
the the battery the battery stuff we're
going to talk about is is truly
revolutionary
uh and essential to uh to tesla's goal
the fundamental the fundamental good of
tesla
it's like if you look back in history
and say what what good did tesla do
um the good will be to what you know by
how many years did we accelerate
sustainable energy
that's like the true metric of of
success um
you know it matters if sustainable
energy
happens faster or slower and and so
that's really
like how i think about tesla and how we
should you know sort of assess our
progress
you know how by how many years did we
accelerate sustainable energy
um and what we're going to talk about
with batteries and and a few other
things
will really explain how we're going to
make a step change improvement
in the acceleration of sustainable
energy thank you
hi folks that was great we're going to
take a short break before we begin the
battery day event
so stay tuned if you're local and here
in the audience today
you can feel free to get out of the cars
and stretch your legs but try to stay
near the cars because we're going to
begin promptly
in a little bit see you soon
i know
all right
hello everyone
sure thanks elon oh hi i'm drew baglino
svp of powertrain and energy engineering
at tesla and i'm incredibly excited to
talk about what we've been doing at
batteries here at tesla
great um so let's see you've got the
clicker yeah okay let's let's uh yes
i'll take it at first perhaps sure um so
obviously the the issues we're facing
are very serious uh
you know with the climate change and um
we're experiencing these issues on a on
a day-to-day basis
um it's incredibly important we
accelerate the advent of sustainable
energy
uh time really matters uh this
presentation
is about accelerating the time to
sustainable energy
so uh the past five years are the
hottest on record
um we have what looks like a wall
for co2 ppm um
it's obviously you know this time is not
like the past
uh it's it's really important that we
take action
um running this uh climate experiment is
insane
so especially when it's just a
transitory one anyway
yes we're gonna run out of these fossil
fuels let's just move to the future
and not run this experiment any longer
yeah
louder you got it okay um
so anyway the
so there is a lot of good news though um
what a lot of people may not be aware
that that wind and solar
comprise 75 of new electricity capacity
in the us this year
so this is a really major
um so
the greatest the grid is going
sustainable
uh very very quickly um
now it's also worth noting that the
length of time the power plants last is
on the order of 25 years so
even if 100 of energy generation was
sustainable it would still take 25 years
to
convert the grid um
and and it's also worth noting that in
the past 10 years
power production from coal has dropped
in half so it went from 46
of electricity in 2010 to 23 in 2020 so
this is a
massive improvement so good things are
happening on a lot of levels which need
to go faster
so in terms of tesla's contribution
we've delivered over a million
electric vehicles 26 billion
electric miles driven and
many gigawatt hours of stationary
batteries uh 17 terawatt hours of solar
generated
so um i think solar is sometimes uh
underweighted at tesla but it is a
massive part of our future
the three parts of a sustainable energy
future are sustainable energy generation
storage and electric vehicles so
we intend to play a significant role in
all three
uh so to achieve to accelerate
accelerate the transition to sustainable
energy must produce more
uh evs that need to be affordable and a
lot more energy storage
while building factories faster and with
far less investment
so goal number one is a terawatt hour
scale
battery production so terra is the new
giga
uh and a terawatt is a
thousand times more than a gigawatt so
uh we used to talk in terms of gigawatts
uh in the future we'll be talking
in terms of uh terawatt hours so this is
uh
what's needed in order to transition the
world to sustainability
um yeah and you can see it's a we're
talking about 100x growth
in batteries for electric vehicles to
achieve this mission
um and we are going to get there just a
matter of how fast and our intention is
to accelerate it
yeah you basically need on the order of
roughly 10 terawatt hours a year of
battery production
to transition the the global fleet of
of vehicles to electric and the average
vehicle lasts 15 years so we're talking
about 150 terawatt hours give or take
during the transition the whole electric
all vehicles
of all types uh uh two electric
yeah so it's a lot of batteries
basically
um and um
yeah so and then on the grid side
uh we have a similar mountain to climb
sixteen hundred times growth from
today's grid batteries to go 100
renewable on the grid
and to take all of the existing heating
fossil fuel uses in homes and businesses
100 electric yeah and this this number
i think i might grow even more depe you
know as the world economy
uh matures and as uh countries with high
populations industrialize
uh we could see this number be even more
but let's say it's like roughly
uh 20 uh to 25
terawatt hours per year sustained for
15 to 25 years to transition the world
to
renewable this is a lot
yeah so today's batteries can't scale
fast enough uh they're just too small
for gigan nevada 150 gigawatt hours per
year is like what we
probably expect to make out of there but
this is really pretty small
in the grand scheme of things that's
only 0.15 terawatt hours
and they cost too much so we would need
135
fully built out nevada gigafactories to
achieve 20 terawatt hours a year
it's not scalable enough of a solution
we need a dramatic rethink
of the cell manufacturing system to to
scale
as fast as we can and should yeah and i
think we should
view this as as more than just a
question of money um
money is sort of like an ethereal thing
but it's really the amount of effort you
have
a certain amount of of effort um
in terms of people and machines and
depending on on
how efficient that that effort is um
you know for a given amount of effort
you you want the most amount of
batteries
so it's not just a question of like well
if we had two trillion dollars you
tomorrow you could make this
it's it's not that easy you actually
need to organize a massive number of
people
build a lot of machines build the
machines that make the machines
and so it's incredibly important to have
that effort
yield the most number of batteries so
and then go to obviously we need to make
uh more affordable cars
um the uh you know i think one of the
things that troubles me the most is that
we don't yet have
a truly affordable car um and that that
is something that we will make in the
future
uh but in order to do that um we've got
to get the cost of batteries down we've
got to make
uh and we've got to be better at
manufacturing and
and we need to do something about this
curve this cur the curve of
of the cost per kilowatt hour of
batteries is not improving fast enough
um
so we we give we've given this a lot of
thought over many years
uh to say okay how can we radically
improve
the the cost per kilowatt hour curve um
it's been somewhat flattening out
actually in in recent years i mean early
growth was promising but you can see
we're kind of plateauing
so that's that's what's motivating us to
to rethink how cells are produced and
designed
yeah exactly so so
um yeah and eb market share is growing
but eb's yeah
aren't still aren't accessible to all um
it's it's
and and you can see as jew were saying
it's like starting to flatten out a
little bit
because uh the rate of improvement of
the affordability of cars is just not
fast enough
so that's why we got battery day
yeah to make the best cars in the world
we design vehicles and factories from
the ground up
next yeah and now we do this
for batteries as well yeah
it's where the the slides don't show up
quite right
this what shows up in the screen it's
not quite what shows up there anyway
okay
different yeah i think it's because
that's yeah
that one's current supposed to be anyway
so let's get started
we have a plan to have the cost per
kilowatt hour
and it's not a plan that rests on a
single innovation
some research project that'll never see
the light of day it's a plan
that has taken creative engineering
and industrialization across every facet
of what makes a cell into a battery pack
from raw material to the finished thing
and we're going to go through that plan
with you today step by step and build up
how we get to these goals and how we
accelerate this transition and make
our vehicles and our grid batteries more
affordable
i mean we basically thought through
every element of the battery or
almost every element there are a few
more elements that we won't get to today
but we will get to in the future
yes so first before we get too far into
it let's talk about
what is in a battery cell we've got the
cap and the
and the can negative and positive
terminals of the cell
when you open that cell you've got a tab
connected to those terminals
what we call the jelly roll which is the
wound electrodes on the inside
you can actually see what this looks
like as you unwind it this is over a
meter long in a typical 2170 cell
so it's quite a long winding process um
and and you can see the tab still there
um and then what to explain what's
actually going on here
we've identified we've got anode cathode
separator
positive and negative terminal watch
what happens as we
uh there we go discharge the cell
got lithium moving from anode to cathode
and then the reverse when we charge the
cell
anode moving from uh lithium moving from
cathode to anode across the separator
this is the basic of what makes all
lithium ion batteries whether they're
what no matter what the form factor is
and when we look at what what's happened
today at least in our products we've
moved from
the 18650 form factor to the 2170 form
factor through great collaboration with
our partners
panasonic new partners like lg and catl
and probably others in the future
yeah actually so slight note on on why
is the one called 18650 although not on
the slide
versus the 2170 is that the the first
two digits refer to the diameter
and the second two they just refer to
the length so that that helps explain
why
these weird what's up with these weird
numbers but like nobody could explain to
me why there was an extra zero
um so i so i said like okay well we're
deleting the zero
that nobody can explain in in future
form factors so that's why it's
technically it's like the 18650
bizarrely
but going forward it's the 2170 because
we just got rid of the extra zero
because it's pointless
um and this was this was a evolutionary
step
going from 1865 to 2170 bringing 50
more energy into the cell but when we
look to
the ideal cell design if we were to do
it ourselves
we need to go beyond just um what we're
looking at us in front of us
and and study the full the full spectrum
of options
so as you can see we we kind of swept
the key
figures of merit how much we can reduce
the cost and how much vehicle
range increases as we change the outer
diameter of the cell
we found a sweet spot somewhere around
46 meters uh millimeters
but it's not just about a bigger form
factor like anybody could make a bigger
form factor any fool
any fool could make a bigger form factor
there are we not any fool
yeah exactly there are problems uh as
you make cells larger in fact
supercharging and thermals in general
become really challenging as you make
bigger cells and this was the challenge
that
our team uh set our sights on to
overcome
and we did we came up with this tablet
architecture
that maybe you've heard about that
that basically removes the thermal
problem from the equation and allows us
to
go to the absolute lowest cost form
factor
um and the simplest manufacturing
process
and this is what this is what we mean
when we when we talk about tablets
it's kind of a beautiful thing uh yeah
that's what these that's what these
t-shirts mean but it's very esoteric
it's like nobody could
figure it out but yeah um we basically
took the existing foils
laser powdered them and enabled dozens
of connections into the active material
through this shingled spiral you can see
with simpler manufacturing
fewer parts 50 50 millimeter versus 250
millimeter
electrical path length uh which is how
we get all the thermal benefits
yeah this is important to appreciate
like basically the the
the distance that that electron has to
travel you know it's just much less
um so uh you actually have a shorter
path length
in a large table a large tablet cell
than you have in the smaller
cell with tabs this is a big deal so
even though the cell is bigger it
actually has
more power uh the power to weight ratio
is actually better
than the smaller cell with with with
halves this is
uh you know again like this is quite
quite hard to do
so it said you know nobody's done it
before um so
uh and it really took a tremendous
amount of effort uh within tesla
engineering to figure out how do we make
a frugal tablet cell
and have it actually work and and
connect that to
the top cap and it's uh there's a whole
bunch of things that we're
you know keeping a little secret source
here that we're not telling everything
um
but uh sometimes what's elegant and
simple is still hard
and we it took us a lot of trials but
we're we're happy where we ended up
yeah i mean everything's simple in
recollection you know after you
like everything it's hard until it's
discovered and then it's simple
um so anyway it's there's a there's a
lot of really cool things going on
uh that that enable uh tablets
and um it's really you know
due to a really great engineering team
drew and the rest of the team have done
amazing work in achieving this
tablets construction um and it sounds i
think it may sort of sound a bit silly
to some people but
this was this is like if for people that
really know cells this is a massive
breakthrough
for cylindricals to be able to to get
rid of the tabs
dramatically simplifies winding and
coding yeah
and has an awesome thermal and
performance benefit yeah
just to elaborate on that a bit it's
like when the cell is
is going going through the the system
the system
it has to keep stopping where all the
tabs are yes so you can't do a contain
you can't do continuous motion
uh uh production uh if you have tabs you
have to keep stopping and and then
there's a rate at which
you can start and stop and accelerate
again and and really slows down the the
rate of production and then sometimes
you get the tabs wrong and you also get
lose a little bit of
of active area it's it's it's really
huge pain in the ass to have tabs
um from a production standpoint yes
um and so when we put it all together
and
go to our new 80 millimeter length
4680 we call this new cell design
we get five times the energy with six
times the power
and enable 16 range increase
just form factor alone uh yeah so
these yeah it's pretty great
i just i just to clarify that when we
see these
um plus six sixteen percent or whatever
the percentage range increases
these are the amounts due just to that
particular innovation
yes so we'll list a whole bunch of
innovations and then when you add them
up you get a total
of improvement in uh energy density and
cost
uh but these numbers are are what refer
to
just this thing yeah and i want to
stress
this is not just a concept or a
rendering we are
starting to ramp up manufacturing of
these cells at our pilot
10 gigawatt hour production facility
just around the corner yeah
so
[Music]
yeah it's a video of uh
some of what's going on in the plan
um now i mean to be clear it will take
about a year to reach the 10 gigawatt
hour capacity
uh so this is important to appreciate
like when you build a factory there's a
certain capacity that you design to
and then uh it takes some period of time
to actually
achieve that capacity so i would say
it's probably about a year before we get
to the 10
hour annualized rate uh with the with
the pilot plant and this is just a pilot
plant uh the
the actual production plants will be
more on the order of
uh you know maybe 200 gigawatt hours
maybe more
over time and
thank you um
but but let's stack up everything we
just saw at the cell level
so just the cell form factor change
enables a 14
dollar per kilowatt hour reduction just
that cell form factor change
and now that you've been teased on this
factory we're going to go on and walk
step by step through that factory
and and discuss a series of of
innovations there
when thinking about the ideal cell
factory we have inspirations
uh behind us in the paper and bottling
industry
where from humble beginnings over a
century of innovation
has enabled mass scale continuous motion
unbelievably low manufacturing cost
and when we think about the lithium ion
industry which is really only in its
third decade of high volume production
it has so far to go to to achieve
similar scale and simplicity and that
that was the inspiration that we set out
to the team as we thought about how to
marry
cell design and manufacturing in the
best possible factory
and let's talk a little bit about what's
in a cell factory
first there's an electrode process where
the active materials are coated into
films onto foils
um then those foil coated foils are
wound in the in the winding process we
just talked about where if you do have
tabs you have to start and stop
a lot then the the jelly roll is
assembled into the can
sealed filled with electrolyte and then
sent to formation
where the cell is charged for the first
time
and and where the sort of the
electrochemistry is set and the quality
of the cell is verified
and we set out at every step of this
process
to try to take that inspiration we just
showed
and and think about how we make those
processes fundamentally better
and more scalable and
one of the most important processes is
where it all begins
the wet process of the of the electrode
coating
and just to give you all sense of scale
i'm gonna walk through what's in that
wet process
you've got mixing where the the powders
are mixed with either a water or a
solvent
solvents for for the cathode um
that mix then goes into a large coat and
dry
oven where the slurry is coated onto the
foil
you know huge ovens tens of meters long
dried
uh and that solvent then has to be
recovered you can see the solvent
recovery system and then finally
the coated foil is compressed to the
final density
and when you're looking at this you're
like wow that's a lot of equipment for
one step
especially when you consider that little
speck
next to the coating oven is a person
this is serious
serious iron involved in making
batteries
wouldn't it be great if we could skip
that solvent step
which is one of those dig a ditch and
then fill it kind of things where you
put the solvent
in and then take it out and recycle it
and just go
straight to dry mix to coat and that's
what the dry process really is about
and in the most basic form
you can see it here on a benchtop
literally
powder in into film as simple as that
i mean it's hard actually uh just to be
clear so
you know if this was easy everyone would
do it so the it's not like
uh dry coating electrode is is actually
uh easy it's it's it's it's actually
very hard to do what appears to be a
simple thing
um and it's it's worth noting like um
you know we did acquire maxwell as like
a little over a year ago i guess um
and you know it's certainly a good
company and everything but the
the the dry coating they had was like
it's like sort of i was called proof of
concept uh since the acquisition we've
we've actually
uh revved the the machine that does the
dry coding four times so we're in
revision for post acquisition of the
machine um and there's still a lot of
work to do
so i would not say this is like
completely in the bag it's still a lot
of work to do
and you know as you go as you scale go
from like bench top to lab to
uh pilot to volume production uh there
are actually major issues that you
encounter it at every level
it's not like you know you make
something work on your
on your bench and bingo now you can make
a bazillion of it absolutely it's
insanely difficult
to scale up um yeah yeah
but if you do scale it up yeah what what
you saw before
becomes this yeah so you can see the
motivation
a 10 times reduction in footprint a 10
times reduction in energy and a massive
reduction in investment
um but as elon was saying simple is hard
yeah
um yeah i mean to be clear i would like
not say that
right now it's just totally working it's
it's it's
close to working but it's not even now
it at the pilot plant level
it is close to working well i can't like
it's fair to say it probably it does
work but with not a good
not a high yield yeah so we're still
ironing out the kinks but we've made
tens of thousands of cells thousands of
kilometers of electrode
i mean we are on the fourth generation
of the equipment so we've learned a lot
along
along the way yeah i mean it is super
demanding because every atom has its
place if you want to deliver
the energy density and the cycle life
and the supercharging yeah
but we're but we're we're confident that
we will get there but it will be a lot
of work along the way
there's a clear path to success but a
ton of work between here and there
yeah so but this is a really profound
improvement again for people that know
battery
uh manufacturing this is uh this is
gigantic
um we'll probably be on on machine
revision
six or seven by the time we do large
scale production um
the rate at which the machines are being
improved is extremely rapid like
literally every
three or four months is a new rev yeah
and beyond the electrode
we continue to innovate on every other
process step so let's talk a little bit
about
uh assembly which is next
the key to a high performing assembly
line
is accomplishing processes while in
motion
continuous motion and
thinking of the line as a highway max
velocity down the highway no start and
stop no city driving exactly no
stop lights and traffic lights or
anything you want the highway
i want the highway yeah and together
with our internal design team
that makes this equipment and designs
this equipment we coupled
thinking about how to make the best sell
with thinking about how to make the best
equipment
so that we could accomplish the fastest
parts per minute rates on all of these
tools
and through all of that development we
were able to get to the point where
we can uh implement assembly lines
one line 20 gigawatt hours seven times
increase in output per line and when
you're thinking about scalability
and pure effort having one line be 7x
the capability
is just effort multiplying yeah
so
yeah you can sort of think about like
the sort of the fundamental physics of a
factory or something like
um i think it's actually quite a lot
like the rocket equation uh where
uh you've got basically the equations
you've got your exhaust velocity and
then the
log of the start end masses so it's
basically saying
you know how fast are things going and
what percentage of your
the factory volume is doing useful work
and conveyance does not count as useful
work
so only the value added steps yeah if
you
if you break the factory down into uh
cubic meter sections
um and say uh or smaller could be like
one you know one liter sections
and say uh is a majority of this volume
doing useful work you would be astounded
at how bad most factories are they're
like maybe two or three percent
including a factory in fremont um so
i think it is possible to get to at
least uh 10 times that
of volumetric efficiency uh so more like
you know 30 percent
uh ish maybe more um and be 10x better
which means the factory can be 10 times
smaller um and then the other thing is
how fast are things going
through the factory it's like speed and
density um
the the fa the faster you go like if a
factory that's moving
at say twice the speed of another
factory is equivalent to two two
factories basically
and the the company that will be
successful uh is the
company that with one factory can
accomplish what other companies take
two or three or four factories to do so
this is what we're trying to do here
is say okay how do we uh whether with
one factory achieve what maybe five or
even
ten factories would normally be required
to achieve and and the vertical
integration with the
machine design teams at you know groman
and
and and high bar and others allows us to
really
accomplish that because we don't have
all these edge conditions between one
piece of equipment another we can design
the entire machine to be one machine
and remove all these unnecessary steps
yeah
i mean basically tesla is aiming to be
the the best at manufacturing
of any company on earth uh this is the
thing that's actually most important in
the long run
i think um you know just from a company
standpoint and from
basically um achieving sustainability as
fast as possible
but i think also for long-term
competitiveness um eventually every
every car company will have long-range
electric cars
um you know eventually every company
will have autonomy
i think but not every company will be
great at manufacturing uh tesla will be
absolutely head and shoulders above
anyone else in manufacturing that is our
goal
manufacturing is hard and hard problems
are fun to solve
um okay now let's talk about formation
in a in a typical cell factory formation
represents 25
of the investment and what is formation
is it's charging and discharging cells
and verifying the quality of the cell
turns out we've charged and discharged
billions and billions of cells in our
vehicle so we know a thing or two about
that
the typical formation set up is you
charge and discharge each cell
individually in our car we charge
thousands of cells at once
and we took our principal and our power
electronics leveraging
power wall vehicle battery management
systems and others to dramatically
improve
the the formation equipment uh cost
effectiveness and density
86 reduction in formation investment
75 reduction in footprint so
you want to take this one sure so
essentially what this translates to
based on what we know today is about a
75 reduction
uh in the investment per kilowatt hour
uh oh gig what hour
it's it's just uh basically four times
better
than the current state of the art to the
best of our knowledge uh and uh
i think there's probably room to improve
even beyond that definitely
uh definitely yeah um so
uh we're able to from a volume
standpoint
actually get what um in in a smaller
form factor
than giga nevada uh we were able to get
uh many times the the the uh
cell output so uh you can see like
basically we can get a terawatt hour
in l in less space than it took to make
a gigawatt hour
you know 150 gigawatt hours so this is
pretty profound you know it's like i
would actually not have thought this was
possible
uh several years ago that we could
actually get to terawatt our scale
in less in less space than what we
currently envision for doing 150
gigawatt hours
yes simpler accelerates terawatt hour
scale and that's what we need to do to
accelerate our mission
um and you know as elon said we're going
to try to even
improve on this as we uh push towards
our goals
which are yeah so
uh this is just for
uh this is just talking about uh tesla
internal cell production
um as i tweeted out earlier we will
continue to
uh use our cell suppliers the panasonic
and uh
lg and catl um and
so this is 100 gigawatt hours
supplemental to
uh what we buy from suppliers um and uh
yeah essentially th this this does like
reduce our weighted average cost
of a cell because uh if it but it does
it allows us to make a lot more cars and
a lot more stationary storage
um and um and then long term
we're uh expecting to make on the order
of uh
3 000 gigawatt hours or or three
terawatt hours per year um
i think we can we think we've got a good
chance of achieving this actually before
2030 but i i highly confident that we
could do it by by 2030.
when you look at the size of that
factory on the previous page it really
shows how enabling all these
advancements are in achieving a three
terawatt hour
goal by 2030.
and not only is all of that
manufacturing innovation
fantastic for enabling scale it's also
an additional 18
reduction in dollar per kilowatt hour at
the battery pack level but wait there's
more
but wait there's more yeah
so we have a manufacturing system we've
got a cell design
what are the active materials we're
going to put in that cell design let's
talk about the anode first let's talk
about silicon
why is silicon awesome it's awesome
because it's the most abundant element
in the earth's crust after oxygen which
means it's everywhere it's sand
yeah sand is silicon dioxide yeah
and it happens to store nine times more
lithium than graphite which is the
typical anode material in lithium ion
batteries today
so why isn't everybody using it the main
reason is because the challenge with
silicon is that
it expands 4x when fully charged with
lithium
and basically all of that expansion
stress on the particle the particles
start
cracking they start electrically
isolating you lose
capacity the energy retention of the
battery starts to fade
and it also gums up with a passivation
layer that has to keep reforming as the
particles expand yeah basically with
silicon the cookie crumbles and gets
gooey
that's basically what happens good
analogy yeah um and current approaches
to solve this which exists i mean we
have silicon in
in the cars that you're all in right now
are involved
highly engineered expensive materials uh
in in the scheme of things now they're
still great and they enable some of the
benefits of silicon they just don't
enable all of it and they're not
scalable enough
and you can see some of the things that
that maybe you've heard of
sio silicon with with carbon or silicon
nanowires
you know that's kind of the space right
now what we're proposing
is a step change in capability and a
step changing cost
and what that really is is to just go to
the raw metallurgical silicon itself
don't engineer
the base metal just start with that and
design for it to expand
in how you think of the the particle in
the electrode design and how you
you code it yeah i'm not sure if you saw
those basically a dollar
per kilowatt hours um basically if you
if you use
simple silicon it's dramatically less
than even the silicon that is currently
used in
the batteries that are made today um and
you can use a lot more of it
the anode would cost yeah with this
silicon and the anode costs
a dollar and 20 cents a kilowatt hour
[Music]
yeah um
and how does it work start with raw
metallurgical silicon
stabilize the surface with an elastic
ion conducting polymer coating
that is applied through a very scalable
approach
no no no like chemical vapor deposition
no highly engineered high capac
solutions
and then integrated in the electrode
through a robust network formed out of a
highly elastic binder
um and in the end by leveraging this
silicon to its potential
we can increase the range of our
vehicles by an additional 20
just this improvement yeah it gets
cheaper and
longer range
[Music]
yeah and and when we take that anode
cost reduction we're looking at another
five percent
dollar per kilo kilowatt hour reduction
at the battery pack level
and there's more
let's talk about cathodes what is a
battery cathode
cathodes are like bookshelves where the
metal you know the nickel the cobalt the
manganese or aluminum is like the shelf
and the lithium is the book and really
what sets apart these different metals
is how many books of lithium they can
fit on the shelves and how sturdy the
shelves are
cobalt is a pretty sorry i'm actually
going to say like it's it's tough to
exactly figure out what the right
analogy is to explain uh cathode
and anode but a bookshelf is probably a
pretty good one um in the sense that
um you you need you need a stable
structure uh to contain the islands um
so you want a structure that does not uh
crumble or get gooey or
basically that that holds its shape in
both the cathode and the anode
as you're moving these ions ions back
and forth uh
you it needs to retain its structure uh
so
if it doesn't retain a structure then
you lose cycle life and your battery
capacity drops very quickly absolutely
um yeah i totally agree and and
i think people are always talking about
like oh what's the cathode going to be
is it ncaa or whatever you know the
thing to consider is just fundamentally
what the nickel the
the metals are capable of and that's
what we have on the chart here
dollar per kilowatt hour cathode of just
the metal using just
lme you know london metal exchange
prices um
versus the energy density of just the
cathode and you can see nickel
is the cheapest and the highest energy
density and that's why
increasing nickel is a goal of ours and
really everybody's in the energy in
in the uh battery industry um but
one of the reasons why cobalt has even
used it all is because
it is a very stable bookshelf and the
challenge with going to
pure nickel is stabilizing that
bookshelf with only nickel
and that's what we've been working on
with our high nickel cathode development
which has zero cobalt in it leveraging
novel coatings and
novel coatings and dopants we can get a
15
reduction in cathode dollar per kilowatt
hour
yeah it's a big deal
but it's not just about nickel you want
to yeah sure
um so in order to scale uh we really
need to make sure that we're not
constrained by total nickel availability
um i actually spoke with the the ceos of
the biggest mining companies in the
world and said
uh please make more nickel it's very
important um
and so i think they are going to make
more nickel
but there's also uh
you know i think we need to have a kind
of a three-tiered approach to
to batteries um so starting with iron
that's kind of like a medium range
and then nickel manganese as sort of a
medium plus
uh intermediate um and then high nickel
for long range applications like cyber
truck and uh the semi
um there's something like like a semi
truck it's extremely important to have
a high energy density in order to get
long range so
um and and just to give sort of iron a
bit um
more time like the uh although the
you know if you look at the uh white
house per kilogram at the cathode level
of um
of iron uh it looks like nickels twice
as good
uh but when you fully considered at the
pack level everything else taken into
account
uh nickel was about maybe 50 or 60
percent better than
uh than iron so iron is not
is a little better than it would seem
when you when you look at it at the
uh the pack level fully considered um
it's not as good as nickel and it goes
like 50 to 60 better
but it's still it's actually pretty good
um and so
you know good for stationary storage and
for
uh medium range applications uh where
energy density is not paramount
and then like i said for intermediate uh
it's kind of a nickel manganese
um and it's uh relatively
straightforward to do
a cathode that's uh two-thirds nickel
one-third manganese
uh which would then allow of us to make
50
more cell volume uh with the same amount
of nickel
and with very little energy trade off
just enough to
to to have you still want to use 100
nickel for something like a
semi truck but but really not much of a
sacrifice yeah
um and you know beyond the metals
because a lot of people spend time
talking about the metals actually the
cathode process itself is a big
target 35 of the cathode dollar per
kilowatt hour
is just in transferring it into its
final form
and so we see that as a big target and
we decided to take that on
um here's a view of the traditional
cathode process
effectively if you start at the left and
you have the metal from the
the mine the first thing that happens is
the metal from the mine is changed into
an intermediate thing called a metal
sulfate
because that's just happened to be what
chemists wanted a long time ago
and then you and then when you're making
the cathode you have to take this
intermediate thing called metal sulfate
add chemicals add a whole bunch of water
a whole bunch of stuff
happens in the middle and at the end you
get that little bit of cathode and a
whole bunch of wastewater and byproducts
yeah
it's insanely complicated if you if you
look at the
total like if you're just like you know
it's a small world journey of uh
i am a nickel atom what happens to me
and it's like
it is crazy like you're going around the
world three times
it's there's like the moral equivalent
of like digging in the ditch filling the
ditch and digging the ditch again
it's total madness basically um and
these things just grew up as just
they're just kind of like legacy things
that
it's like how it was done before and
then they connected the dots
but really didn't think of the whole
thing from like a first principle
standpoint
saying how do we get from uh the nickel
or in the ground
to the finished nickel product for
battery uh and so we've
looked at the entire value chain and
said how can we make this as simple as
possible
and that's what we're proposing here
with our process as you can see
a whole less a whole lot less is going
on here
we get rid of the intermediate metal
water final profit product cathode
recirculate the water no waste water at
all and when you summaries summarize all
of that
it's the 66 reduction in capex
investment
a 76 reduction in process cost and zero
wastewater
much more scalable solution yeah
[Applause]
and then when you think about the fact
that now we're actually just directly
consuming the raw
metal nickel powder it dramatically
simplifies the metal refining
part of the whole process so we can
eliminate billions in battery grade
nickel
intermediate production it's not needed
at all yeah
and uh we can also use that same process
we showed on the previous page
to directly consume the metal powder
coming out of recycled
electric vehicle and grid storage
batteries so this process enables
both simpler mining and simpler
recycling
and now that we have this process
obviously we're going to go and
start building our own cathode facility
in north america and leveraging
all of the north american resources that
exist for
nickel and lithium and just doing that
just
localizing our cathode supply chain and
production
we can reduce miles traveled by all the
materials that end up in the cathode by
80
which is huge for cost yeah i mean to be
clear cathode production would be part
of
our the tesla cell production plant so
just be
you know basically you know uh raw
materials coming from the mine
and from raw materials in the mine
outcomes of battery
and on that note the way the lithium
ends up in the cell is through the
cathode so then we should obviously
on-site
lithium conversion as well which is what
we will do using a new process that
we're going to pioneer
that's a sulfate-free process again skip
the intermediate
33 reduction in lithium cost 100
electric facility co-located with the
cathode plant
yeah so it's important to note that
there is a
massive amount of lithium on earth so
lithium is not like oil there's a
massive amount of it pretty much
everywhere so in fact there's
there's enough lithium in the united
states to convert the entire united
states fleet to
electric like all the cars in the united
st
every vehicle the united states can be
converted to electric using only lithium
that is available in the united states
discovered today that yeah what we
already know is exist people really
haven't even been looking yeah people
haven't
been trying because it's just like
widely available so um
but it is important to say like okay
what is the smartest way to
uh take the ore and extract the lithium
and and do so in an environmentally
friendly way um and
we actually discovered a again looking
at it sort of first principles physics
standpoint
um instead of just the way it's always
been done um
is we found that uh we can actually use
table salt uh sodium chloride
uh to basically extract the lithium from
the ore
um and uh this is nobody's done this
before
to the best of our knowledge nobody's
done this um and it's a
sort of you know all the elements are
reusable it's a very sustainable way of
obtaining lithium
and we actually uh we we we actually got
uh rights to a uh lithium clay deposit
in nevada
over 10 000 acres over 10 000 acres
and then the the nature of the mining is
actually also very environmentally uh
sensitive in that we sort of take a
chunk of dirt out of the ground
or remove the lithium and then put the
chunk of dirt back where it was so
it will look pretty much the same as
before and it will not look
like terrible and yeah it will be nice
nice
so simply mix clay with salt put it in
water
salt comes out with the lithium done
yeah it's pretty crazy
yeah so we're really excited about this
and and there really is enough lithium
in nevada alone
to electrify the entire u.s fleet yeah
that's true actually
just what's in nevada that's uh that's
basically
so much damn lithium on earth it's crazy
it's one of the most common elements on
the planet
um and eventually as we said at the
beginning
when we get to this steady state 20
terawatt hours per year of production
we will transfer the entire
non-renewable fleet
of both power plants home heating and
and
batter and industry heating and vehicles
to electric and at that point we have an
awesome resource in those batteries to
recycle
to make new batteries so we don't need
to do any more mining at that point and
you can see why
the the the difference in the the value
of the
of the material coming back from the
vehicle versus the ground you'd always
go to the vehicle
and we recycle 100 of our vehicle
batteries today
and actually we are starting our pilot
full-scale recycling production uh at
gigafactory reno next quarter
to to continue to develop this process
as as our recycling
returns grew up yeah i mean to date it's
been done by third parties but uh we
think we can we can recycle the
batteries more effectively
especially since uh you know we know our
batteries we're making the same battery
as the thing we're recycling so uh
whereas like third-party recyclers have
to consider batteries of all kinds
yeah and and just to think about
what this actually means the recycling
resource is always 10 or greater years
delayed because
batteries last a really long time but
eventually it is the way
that that all resources will be made
available and that's why we're investing
in this recycling facility
in nevada yeah long-term
new batteries will come from old
batteries uh once the fleet reaches
steady state
right okay so we just talked about
scaling cathode
and recycling all of the benefits
that you just saw are added to this
benefit of a 12
reduction in dollars per kilowatt hour
at the battery pack level
almost at our have the cost goal but
there's one more section
take it away elon so um
there's an architecture that um we've
been wanting to do tesla for a long time
uh and we're finally we finally figured
it out
um and i think it's it's the way that
all electric cars in the future will
ultimately be made uh
it's the right way right away to do
things um
so it's it starts with uh having a
single piece casting
or a single piece casting for the front
buddy and the rear buddy
um and uh in order to do this we uh
commissioned the the largest casting
machine that has ever been made and it's
currently working just uh
over the road at our fremont plant
we have the the it's pretty sweet
um making the uh entire currently making
the entire
uh rear section of the car in a as a
single piece
high pressure die cast aluminum and in
order to do this we actually
uh had to develop our own alloy because
we wanted a high strength casting alloy
that
did not require coatings or heat
treatment uh this is
a big deal for for castings especially
with a
large casting if you heat tweet it
afterwards it tends to deform it kind of
like
does this like potato chip thing so it's
very hard to keep
a large casting uh to have its shape um
so in order to
achieve this there was no alloy that
existed that could do this so we
developed our own alloy
a special aloe aluminum that has high
strength without heat treat and is very
castable
so that's a you know a great achievement
of our materials team
in fact in general we've got a lot of
advanced materials coming for for tesla
that
new alloys and materials that have never
existed before
so uh so you're basically making the
the front and rear of the car as a
single piece um
and then that that then
interfaces to uh what we call it the
structural battery
where the battery for the first time
will have dual use
uh the battery will both have the use as
an energy device
and as structure this this is absolutely
the way things are done
in in the early days of of aircraft they
would carry the fuel tanks as cargo
so the fuel tanks actually had
were quite difficult to carry they were
like basically worse than cargo you
had to kind of bolt them down um
it was very difficult uh and then
somebody said hey
what if we just make the wing tanks what
if we just make the fuel tank in wing
shape
so uh all modern airplanes the fuel tank
your wing is just a a fuel tank in wing
shape
this is absolutely the way to do it um
and then the the fuel tank
serves as dual structure um and it's not
it's no longer cargo
it's it's fundamental to the structure
of the aircraft this was a
major breakthrough we're doing the same
for cars
so
so this is really quite profound uh
the effectively the non-cell portion of
the battery has negative mass
so we save so much mass in the rest of
the vehicle
we save more mass than the rest of
vehicle than the non-cell portion of the
battery
so it's like well how do you really
minimize the mass of a battery make it
negative
make the battery non-cell portion of
battery pack negative
um so um
it also allows us to pack the cells more
densely because we do not have
uh intermediate structure in the battery
pack so instead of having these like uh
supports and stabilizers and stringers
and structural elements in the battery
we now have a lot more
space in the battery because the pack
itself is structural
the and what we do is essentially um
like what we like we instead of having
just um a filler that
is a flame retardant which is currently
what is is in the
three and y battery packs we have a
filler that is a
a structural adhesive as well as flame
retardant
so it effectively glues the cells to the
top and bottom sheet
and this allows you to do shear transfer
between upper and lower sheet
just like if you have like a formula one
uh craft or
like a racing boat and you have a carbon
fiber face sheets and say aluminum
honeycomb between them
uh this uh gives you incredible
stiffness um and it's really the way
that that any super fast thing
works is uh you you create a
basically a a honeycomb sandwich with
with two uh face sheets
uh this is actually even better than
what aircraft do because aircraft do not
do this
um they can't do this because fuel is
liquid so
in our case the batteries are solid so
we can actually use the
the steel shell case of the battery to
transfer
uh shear from the upper and lower face
sheet which makes for an incredibly
stiff structure
even stiffer than a regular car yeah in
fact if this was
if this was in a in a
like a a convertible uh that had no
upper structure
it would be stiffer then that converter
will be stiffer than a regular car
so this is it's just really to have
really major um so improves the mass
efficiency of the battery
um and then those castings also quite
important because you want to
transfer load into the structural
battery pack uh in a very smooth
continuous way
um so you don't um put arbitrary point
loads
into the battery um so you kind of have
to you want to sort of feather the load
out from the front and rear
into the structural battery um it also
allows us to
uh use uh to move the the cells
uh closer to the center of the of the
car um
because we don't have the the the in the
top one we got that sort of all the
supports and stuff
so the volumetric efficiency of the
structural pack
is is much better than a non-structural
pack and we actually bring the cells
closer to the center
um and uh because they're closer to the
center
uh it reduces the probability of of a
side impact
uh potentially contacting the cells
because they have it has to go
in any kind of side impact has to go
further in order to reach the cells
uh it also proves uh what's called the
polar moment of inertia
uh which is that you can think of like
when there's a
like uh ice skater arms out or arms in
arms in you rotate faster
so if you can bring things closer to the
center you reduce the problem of inertia
and that means you can
the car maneuvers better it just feels
better you don't know why but it just
it just feels more agile so it's really
cool this is
really major um like i said so 10
mass reduction in the body of the car 14
range
increase uh 370 fewer parts
so
i mean i really think that that long
term and any cars that do not
uh take this architecture will not be
competitive and it's not just
at the product level a better product um
but in the factory it's a massive
simplification
you saw the part removal um you know
it's casting machines
it's the structural battery pack so
we're looking at over 50
reduction in investment per gigawatt
hour 35
reduction in floor space and we'll
continue to improve that as we make the
vehicle factory of the future
yeah so is major improvements on all
fronts from the cell
all the way to the the vehicle um
and in addition to the improvements we
just said on enabling additional range
and improving the structural performance
of the vehicle
it is worth another seven percent dollar
per kilowatt hour reduction at the
battery pack level
bringing our total reductions now to 56
dollars per kilowatt yeah
all right so stacking it up we're not
just talking about
uh cost or range we've got to look at
all the facets
so range increase we're unlocking up to
54
increase in range for our vehicles and
energy density for our energy products
uh 56 reduction in dollars per kilowatt
hour at the battery pack level
and a 69 reduction in investment per
gigawatt hour which is the true enabler
when we talk back about how do we
achieve this scale problem here
yeah uh and yeah so
um i think it's pretty nice that
investment per kilowatt
for gigawatt hour reduction is 69 i mean
who would have thought yeah
just happened to happen out that way
i mean 0.420 of course
um yeah so what what this
uh enables uh us to do is achieve a new
trajectory in the reduction of
of uh cell cost and um now to be clear
it will take us
probably a year to 18 months to start
realizing
these uh these advantages and probably
to fully realize the advantages probably
it's about three years or thereabouts
so um you know it's it's not like
uh if we could do this instantly we
would um but
it's it's really um i think what this
bodes
for it's just really bodes well for the
future and means that
the long-term scaling of tesla and and
uh the sustainable energy products that
we make
will be massively increased so uh you
know what tends to happen as companies
get bigger as things tend to slow down
um well actually they're going to speed
up
and they have to speed up if we're going
to accelerate the transition to
sustainable energy
yeah i mean long term we you know we
want to try to
replace about you know at least one
percent of the total
vehicle fleet on earth which is about
two billion vehicles
so long term we want to try to make
about 20 million vehicles here
but i think it's important to point out
that when we talked about three terawatt
hours by 2030 the problem is a 20
terawatt hour problem
so everybody needs to be accelerating
their efforts to accomplish these
objectives it doesn't matter where you
are in the value chain
there is a ton to do you need to rethink
from first principles how you do it so
that you can scale
to meet all of our objectives yep
anyone uh sure what does this mean
what does it mean for what does what
does this mean for our future products
uh so uh we're we're confident that long
term we can design
and manufacture a a compelling 25 000
electric vehicle um so
you know this this this has always been
our dream from the beginning of the
company
i even like wrote a blog piece about it
um because um
you know our first car was was an
expensive sports car
and and then then it was like slightly
less expensive sedan
and then finally it's sort of a i don't
know mass market premium
but you know like the model 3 and model
y um but it really it was always our
goal to try to make an affordable
electric car
and um i think probably uh
like i said about about three years from
now uh we're confident we can make a
very calm
uh very compelling 25 000 electric
vehicle
uh that's also fully autonomous and when
you think about
the 25 000 price point you have to
consider how much
how much less expensive it is to own an
electric vehicle
yeah so actually it it it becomes even
more affordable at that 25 000
price point yeah so we have uh and
extreme performance and range
um and uh we should probably talk about
the you know model s plaid
yeah what about that
yeah so
uh yeah anyway we we took the latest
plot out to laguna seca on sunday you
got
a minute 30. um and uh we think probably
there's another three seconds or more to
take off that time
uh so uh we're confident the model s
plaid will
achieve the the best track time of any
production vehicle ever of any kind
two-door or otherwise
[Music]
um and you can order it now uh and it's
uh
available uh uh basically end of next
year
so and now we'll move to q a
absolutely so which invite we'll invite
a few people on stage
come on up team
this is just a small portion of the team
but uh it would be great to
you know show you some more of the team
and um and when we do q a
we can like you know give various people
different uh
questions to answer sounds great
actually i don't know how we're getting
the questions actually i don't know
either
okay well you can just like you
you can maybe get out of the car for two
seconds and yell it at us i don't know
hey how do we get any questions oh
they're
mics okay wait for them they're mics
okay great great
all right okay we'll definitely need to
give people mics because otherwise
there's no way
um sorry
okay all right we're gonna pass some
mics out
uh we don't have a name for the 25 000
car yet it's a great question though
uh yes uh we will be manufacturing uh
sales in in berlin
yep
thermal management system for homes
oh oh you mean like the home hvac um
yeah that i mean that's a pet project
that i'd love to get going on
um i don't know maybe we'll start start
working on that next year
um because i just think this man you
could really make a way better home hvac
system that's
really quiet and super efficient and uh
yeah super energy efficient and also has
like a
you know a way better filter uh you know
for particles and um
uh yeah just and it works uh very
reliably
and and we've already developed that for
the car like so the the heat pump uh
in the model y uh is really
pretty spectacular uh i mean it's tiny
it's efficient
it has to last for 15 years uh
it's got to work in all kinds of
conditions from you know
the coldest winter to the hottest summer
so we've actually already done a massive
amount of the work necessary for
a really kick-ass home hvac and they
could also like stack them so if you
want to
say uh depending upon the size your
house or whatever how much you need you
can just
you can just basically stack them um and
just have a very compelling super
efficient home hvac and then you can
also
uh communicate with the car and it'll
it'll know when you're coming home
so it's like oh i don't need to keep the
house cold all day i just
you know cool it down because i knew
you're coming home
so the pack can communicate with the car
and just like really dial it into
when you actually need cooling and
heating it'd be great
fun product yeah who's next
hello hey guys eli here uh from tesla's
club my tesla adventure
uh just quick question so i'm a huge fan
of car camping in my tesla with my dream
case like my all-time favorite activity
is it going to be possible to get
climate control to the back of the cyber
truck because that would be the ultimate
camping machine if we can get all night
climate control
uh we'll try to do that yeah i agree
that would be
that would be really cool yeah
all right who's next hello uh long time
fan
a great guy uh just a question how does
the
ice industry look like for uh in the
future
uh well i don't think there will be an
ice industry long term
yeah i mean
well i guess there might be like a few
things that are like it's a like curious
thing like i mean
there's still like some steam engines
made somewhere uh but like they're just
basically
sort of quirky collector's items i mean
that will be the future of the internal
combustion engine car
hi elon to your left here in the white
model y ryan mccaffrey from the
from the ride the lightning tesla
podcast uh curious about cybertruck it
was interesting to see where you had it
in
on the battery technology front i'm sort
of curious
what you see for it in the production
front is its volume you know trucks are
so popular in america
do you see its volume equaling the three
or the y in the future and
also is the uh did you do were you able
to get
tesla is able to legally be sold in
texas as part of the gigatexas deal
um well it's hard to say what the volume
exactly would be for the cyber truck the
the orders are
gigantic so and we have like i don't
know
well over half a million orders i think
maybe six or six hundred thousand that's
a lot
basically we start counting um so i i
think there's probably room for
i don't know at least like a unit volume
of like
250 to 300 000 a year maybe more
um so now we are designing the cyber
truck to meet the american spec because
if you try to design a car to meet the
global
that's the superset of all global
requirements it basically
you can't make the cyber truck it's
impossible um so
it's really is designed for the american
market but this is the biggest market a
north american market is the biggest
market for pickup trucks by far or
large pickup trucks and then i think for
uh
we'll probably make an international
version of of the cyber truck that'll be
kind of smaller you know kind of like a
tight wolverine package
um it'll still be cooler but it'll be
it'll be smaller because you just can't
make a giant truck like that for most
markets
um so yeah but it's gonna be great uh
and i i don't know i think probably
we'll be able to sell directly in texas
um we do pretty well right now uh
but it is a bit weird not being able to
actually conclude a transaction in texas
but
it's got to be like you know a click on
a server based in california
so um but really we can do leasing in
texas we're not selling but
i hopefully that'll get cleared up in
the future
elon great job with everything that
you're doing frost gerber from gerber
kawasaki
your team's amazing what i'm most
curious about these innovations
are incredible but on my drive up here
fully on autopilot for 400 miles
the entire state is brown and this is
ultimately about climate
has there been some analysis done if all
these things are achieved what will its
direct
impact be on climate
uh well i mean i think we'll have a very
significant impact because it will
stop the um the co2 ppm from growing
as it is every year um and i mean i
should say like
you know um you know i try to view
the whole climate thing for you know as
a science question
as much as possible you know science you
always question your hypothesis
is it true is it not true or assign a
probability to a given hypothesis
and i should say that my my original
interest in electric vehicles
uh predates the climate issue um like
just when i was in high school is like
i thought man if we don't figure out
electric cars the whole economy is going
to collapse when we run out of oil
so it's like we better figure out
electric cars and sustainable energy
or civilization is going to crumble um
and then it was only kind of later that
the
uh significance of the climate risk uh
became apparent
um and uh we were also able uh using
tracking and other types of technology
to access a lot more
fossil fuels than previously thought um
which is
you know uh helpful for lowering the
cost of gasoline but it's pretty bad for
uh the total uh tonnage of co2 that you
could put in the atmosphere it's not
greatly
beyond what people previously thought so
um but this is you know as we were just
going through this presentation it's
like it is a absolutely monumental
task to accelerate uh the advent of
sustainable energy
i mean the entire global economy is
still you know
more than 99 percent dependent on or
called roughly 99
dependent on fossil fuels um so although
electric cars can get a lot of press
right now they they're still and and
there's still very few as a percentage
of the total global fleet is practically
nothing
it's i would say yes less than one
percent of the global fleet is electric
right now um you know because of two
billion cars and trucks and we're not in
use
so so there's a massive uh amount of
work ahead
just it's just insane like hard to
comprehend how much work is ahead to
get the new vehicle production to be
sustainable
uh to um massively increase the amount
of stationary storage which is critical
because
uh renewable energy is is intermittent
uh wind and solar is
is intermittent sometimes the wind
doesn't blow and this obviously sun
doesn't shine at night
so you got to have batteries um
a massive massive number of batteries so
it's yeah it's hard to measure in direct
impact but it's it's an experiment that
we shouldn't be
performing and the sooner we can sort of
end the experiment
consider we can kind of move on in a
fully sustainable way that is actually
lower cost i mean i think the thing that
people
haven't fully internalized is once we do
get to the 25k car
the ownership cost of that car is
incredibly lower than the prior car and
then
on the solar side and wind with the cost
of solar and wind coming down and with
batteries coming down
with them the actual cost of energy on
the grid
is going down so we're sort of moving
towards towards a sustainable lower cost
future
so there's not like a sacrifice that's
true it is a false dichotomy to
say that it's like it's either
prosperity or sustainability
uh this is often used you know by oil
and gas to say like oh
well do you want people to lose their
jobs do you want to have you want lower
people's standards
standards of living do you want to you
know make all these economic sacrifices
uh really in order to have
sustainability and the reality
as drew was saying is that a sustainable
energy is going to be lower cost
not higher cost than fossil fuels
um quick question for you um
right here in front first uh thanks for
having everyone and
is telling a friend the one company to
go work for that's going to have the
biggest
structural impact over the next 10 years
of scale it's probably tesla so
kudos to everyone at tesla for what
they've done to this point in going
forward
the two questions for you as you've
looked at the auto and the storage
markets i know you've talked about it at
kind of 50 50 long term
but it seems like a lot of the battery
cost curve achievements that you're
seeing
presented today really make some of
these storage
opportunities much more feasible over
the next five years
and so i guess the first part of the
question is does your calculus upon
learning and improving these things
change on that 50 50 mix or is there a
role where storage becomes bigger
and then the second part of the question
with with all these huge grand visions
who's going to be with tesla
from a corporate perspective
accomplishing these things obviously
tesla can't do it alone
but when you look at some of the
traditional auto industry or power
etc i don't see a lot of other teslas
um well actually so there's a lot of
companies in china that i think are
doing great work
uh with electric vehicles and uh also
with stationary storage
um although we don't see that much in
the us yet but i think probably we will
in the future
i don't know i mean obviously we're
doing everything we can to encourage uh
other companies to move to uh
sustainable transport
um and also you know make stationary
storage batteries
um you know we opened up a made our
patents freely available
um uh
you know we really try to tell these
companies hey you really need to do this
or you won't exist in the future
uh but they don't believe it you know so
i mean we've
we've talked until we're blue in the
face what are we supposed to do
um but we really are hopeful that other
companies will also
uh do what we're doing and that will
make the a sustainable future come
sooner
from a fundamental market size
perspective like we did the first
like ground-up work to show the size of
the
of the market in terawatt hours and they
are roughly 50
50. 10 terawatt hours for transportation
10 terawatt hours for the grid
um and part of that is because the grid
batteries
because when you're making a power plant
you're making a large investment
um our 25-year assets are greater
um you know if they were if the grid
batteries were
10-year kind of things the grid market
would be
bigger but because it's a longer
duration asset they're
roughly the same size thinking long term
um is there any other segments that this
new battery will be able to disrupt
or electrify um beyond just the initial
model 2 or cheaper sedan like a boat
boring company luke plane where are you
golly are you there what's up
right here okay great it's like it's
like ventriloquism here you know it's
like
we just get the sound out of the speaker
it can't tell where the heck is coming
from
yeah any hands or is the model 2 such a
big deal because it decreases the cost
of transportation that that is really
the disruption or
should we get height that this new cost
curve opens up different vehicle
categories like a high passenger density
bus
boring loop boat plane
um well i mean there's
there are batteries in limited
production right now that do exceed 400
uh
wattage per kilogram which i think is
about the number you need for
a decent range medium range uh aircraft
um and uh i think our batteries will
over time start to approach the 400
watts per kilogram range as well
so uh yeah i mean i think
over time we'll see all modes of
transport uh with the ironic exception
of rockets
transition to sustainability uh or to to
electric basically
um on the on the rocket front uh what
we're planning to do is
uh like about eighty percent of starship
is oxygen is
liquid oxygen um and uh we're actually
already uh
run running a power line to be able to
use wind power to create the liquid
oxygen
so we're making you know some decent
progress on uh
sustainability on the rocket front but
there's just no way to have an electric
rocket
and it's important for the future of
life and consciousness that we become a
multi-planet species so
gotta keep doing that
hi elon hello josh phillips here retail
investor
i have a question in regards to the
lithium and nickel
industries and the likely price spikes
and shortages of high grade materials
the ev industry is likely to see if they
don't
act fast to address future supply
tesla have clearly made the right moves
that are necessary
but there's a real worry that the
potential supply issues and price spikes
will create a drag on the rest of the
industry and therefore a drag on global
eevee adoption what advice would you
give to the ev and mining industries to
quickly solve this
looming hurdles because for a
sustainable energy future
the spice must flow thank you
yeah indeed the spice must flow
the new spice um
i don't know i think the
you know the i i'm not sure like i guess
we can try to like basically uh overdo
it in cell production and perhaps supply
cells to others
but we do see the fundamental
fundamental constraint as total cell
production that's why we're putting so
much effort into making sales
um and kind of reinventing uh trying to
reinvent every aspect of cell production
from uh mining the ore to a complete
battery pack
um because it's the fundamental
constraint it's no we're not getting
into the cell business because
we uh you know just for the hell of it
it's because it's the fundamental
constraint it's the thing that is
uh the limiting factor for uh rapid
growth
um but uh we we could certainly try to
overdo it on cell
cell production and perhaps uh sell
sells to others
um although we are going at absolute top
speed so it's like
it's not like we're holding it back um
but i i think like just making really
efficient cars
and uh you know there have lower drag
coefficient
um low loading resist
rolling resistance uh efficient
powertrains
um i mean that's kind of what we've done
in order to make
uh iron phosphate uh still have a good
range
um so the iron prices face
high space lower energy density a
solution but um
there's um you know while there are some
limitations on the total amount of
nickel produced
every year there's really no limit on
the iron there's so much iron it's
ridiculous
so you can really scale up uh iron
phosphate
um you know at a raw materials basis
faster more than you can nickel but yeah
and just
just to point out you know when we were
walking through this presentation we
intentionally
separated all the different aspects the
benefits of structural
battery apply to a iron-based cathode in
the same way they apply to a nickel
based
cathode so you get longer-range
iron-based vehicles
and also the silicon benefit can apply
to the iron-based vehicles as well so
there's
we can do a lot to extend the range of
an iron-based vehicle which is why
it's a key part of the roadmap going
forward and then i invited turner up
here to talk about what the mining
industry can do yeah um
diversification on the cathode side is
obviously massive and
evs are all about efficiency and so for
the ev industry for the vehicle industry
we need to see powertrain efficiency
really increase at
all other companies matching tesla power
train efficiency so that everyone can
have that diversified cathode approach
where lfp is used in medium range
and and even really make a 300 mile
vehicle with lfp
um and really the goal that we were
trying to present here
was a model for vertical integration
strategic vertical integration that
a lot of different people can do what we
need to see
is vertical integration that shortens
the f the process
path from mine to cathode and
you know what we're doing here is is is
novel and we're trying to push
the industry in that direction so you
know we're presenting a model here that
that anyone can can follow yeah
in fact if there's anything that you
guys want to comment on uh feel free to
step forward and say something i i think
the key is to be smart about your
chemistry choices
your materials choices yeah if you're
smart about your materials choices
um the spice will continue to flow you
don't you don't need to use
the same kind everywhere and if you
it's about strategically planning it out
and and for miners
i think we are incentivizing them quite
a bit to ramp up their production
yeah and actually we had good calls like
they're all motivated
i think i think that they they've been
sort of sitting back being like are you
gonna grow like crazy
and we're like yeah we're gonna grow
like crazy and then i think this
indicates we're going to grow like crazy
and that's what the miners want to hear
and then they'll go make the investments
hello elon uh this is ben olympic i'm a
musician i was wondering
does tesla have any um future plans to
make partnerships with music companies
like it has done with 10 cent games or
things like that for you guys to
actually
kind of expand your services um for
artists
and other types of creative people to
get involved in you know producing
content that can be part of the tesla
ecosystem or so other people that do
creative things can get involved with
you guys
um well we don't uh
we haven't really thought about that
much but i suppose it's probably
something we should think about
um we will be providing a title
on tesla's um so you know we're
providing
you know music more music sources uh
that people can choose from
and uh just generally trying to improve
the entertainment experience in the cars
and i think actually as we go to a more
autonomous future
uh the the importance of
entertainment and productivity will
become greater and greater
um i mean to agree that if if you're
just basically sitting in your car
the car is fully autonomous and driving
somewhere it's kind of like being in a
i think you know the car is essentially
your chauffeur and
and then uh the things that become
important are okay well let's uh
let's have good entertainment and uh you
know if you want to do some productivity
stuff
then that actually starts to become much
more important because you're no longer
spending your attention driving the car
so it'll be extremely important in the
future should we do some of the say.com
questions okay
should we do the second one uh yeah the
first one i think we already
answered like if we're if we have um if
we're able to make enough sales we
which we'll try to do or we will supply
other companies
uh it's definitely not an intentional
effort to keep the sales to ourselves
uh if we can make enough for other
companies we'll we will
supply them and we're trying to do you
know the right thing for
advancing the sustainable energy
whatever that that that is
so vehicle degraded we get asked that a
lot
i think one thing that's important to
note is the
vehicle to grid it doesn't unless you
have a
power cut off like you need to cut off
your main supply to the grid otherwise
if you're
if you lose the power in your house
you'll basically just backflow
energy to the grid so just having a
reversal in the in the power flow does
not actually
uh keep the lights on um you need a
whole
separate system to cut off power to the
grid
um and i think there's also the case
that people really want the freedom to
be able to drive
and to charge at their house
and it's obviously very problematic if
uh
you know you get to morning and your car
instead of being charged it discharged
into the house and then
you sort of okay now i can either drive
or
not use the battery to power my house uh
i think
it's actually going to be better or for
people's freedom of action to have a
power wall
um and a car separate um and then you
then it's uh
you know everything works the the you
know and you add that you basically
combine that with solar
either solar retrofit a solar glass
solar glass roof
um and a local battery storage so you
basically become your own utility
um and then the the car is
you know can be charged also with solar
um i i think that's like the
stuff that works uh you know that said
like we can certainly do
vehicle to grid um i think we could like
we could basically enable that
with software in europe or something
right uh yeah
um we are future generations of power
electronics we will be able to do this
more or less everywhere from a like
energy market participation perspective
but but yeah from a backing up the house
and
it just so happens that the way the
north american
connectors are on all the cars in north
america it doesn't matter whether it's
the tesla connector or the
the connector that the other vehicles
have doesn't actually support powering
your home it's
unfortunate so you need an additional
hardware to do that
um but but but yeah in the future all
versions of our vehicles will be able to
at least do bi-directional
power flow for the purposes of energy
market participation but even for that
it's important to remember that your car
isn't plugged in 24 7.
so it's kind of an unpredictable uh
resource for the grid it'll have a value
but it's not the same as a stationary
battery
pack yeah honestly a vehicle to grid uh
sounds good but i think actually has
a much lower utility than people think
um
i i think very very few people would
actually use vehicle grid and we
actually had
with the original roadster we had
vehicle-to-grid capabilities nobody used
it
how do we find the engineers to do
everything we're saying how do we find
the engineers to do all these things
uh well uh i i guess we recruit we've
recruited a lot of engineers from all
parts of the world
um you know i think tesla has a good
reputation for
doing exciting engineering and that
tends to attract the
a lot of the top engineers in the world
because they know that their efforts
at tesla will really
serve the greater good um and and we're
super hardcore
about engineering um you know tesla is
like first and foremost
in an engineering company it's like
hardcore engineering is what we do
um like this the sheer amount of
hardcore engineering done tesla is
insane
um and if you look at say
uh there's various surveys done of
engineering schools uh
where do you want to go um like what's
your top choices and actually the top
two choices
um last you know last few years have
been
uh tesla and spacex so sometimes it's
tesla first sometimes spacex first but
those are the two top ones
yeah i mean if you are motivated to
solve some of these problems which are
the hardest problems in the world to
solve that really fundamentally enable
the future we all
need uh please reach out yeah and help
us work on these problems
absolutely and like you said the battle
is far from over um
you know less than one percent of the
global automotive fleet has been
converted to electric
um and uh and even
maybe 0.1 less than 0.1 percent of
stationary storage has been done
so stationary storage has barely begun
uh
converting the global vehicle fleet to
electric has barely
begun so there's still a massive amount
of engineering work to be done at tesla
and other companies to accelerate this
transition to sustainability
hey can you guys hear me uh this is
jordan from mark asset management
um so you've talked about the importance
of the factory and you've mentioned the
ground-up design process and a lot of
the new things that you're going to be
doing or started to do in
shanghai berlin and austin can you just
maybe help us understand and
quantify like how financially meaningful
all of those improvements will be and
then given what you're trying to
accomplish
as a company is it fair to assume that
the vast majority of improvement will be
given back to the customer in the form
of lower prices
um yeah i mean it's it i think certainly
uh we will uh try to give back as much
as possible to the customers it's not
like you know
it's like tesla's profitability is crazy
high uh you know our average
profitability for last four quarters of
like maybe one percent
so uh just to be clear it's not like you
know we're minting money
uh our evaluation makes it seem like we
are but we're not
um so we do want to try to
make the price as as competitive as we
can without
like losing money and if you lose money
then you you know keep doing if you keep
losing money you'll die
so we have to uh this thing called
profit is just like we need to bring in
more money than we spend otherwise we're
dead
so but affordability is key to how we
scale right like the demand goes
non-linear as you reduce the
the price of the car yeah i mean it's
important to sort of separate
the difference between affordability and
value for money
uh or desirability of the product so uh
you know for a lot of people they want
to buy a tesla they simply don't have
enough money
we could make the car infinitely
desirable but if somebody does not have
enough money they can't buy it
um sometimes you know if people
you know kind of forget this it's like
it's it's not it's
like somebody people have to have enough
money to buy the car
um and and just making a car super
desirable but expensive does not mean
they can afford it so
it's absolutely important that critical
that we make cars that people can that
people can actually afford
yeah um so
over here some of these things uh scroll
down or something
oh uh when do you expect tesla vehicles
to beat
ice vehicles on initial purchase price
i think a way to answer that question is
in the classes of vehicles we sell
today we're already doing that yeah
we're already pretty yeah
pretty close um and then factoring in
total cost of ownership
um the fact that electric wheels
vehicles require much less servicing
um and are way cheaper to run uh when
you when you look at like
you know total cost of ownership and you
can obviously lease a car so
if you just like lease a car or or get a
loan for a car you've got your
sort of monthly payment and then your
cost for
either gasoline or electricity and their
cost of servicing
and the the fully considered cost of an
electric car is
much less than a gasoline car of the
same nominal purchase price
you know i mean that said and like maybe
on the order of you know three years
uh when we can do um
a lower cost like a 25 000 car
um you know i think that will be
basically on par maybe slightly better
than a comparable
gasoline car so i think maybe it's it's
on the order of three years
ish
however the technology advancements in
increased vertical integration of
battery manufacturing influence your
ability to improve the environmental and
social impact of the supply chain
and i think yeah i think we've sort of
have said that already yeah
do you have some ability to scroll
through this i just scroll away
are we covered recycling yeah let's just
scroll until we've got stuff we haven't
covered
well we've definitely covered that topic
one of the things things we've already
answered i think
covered that
that one
i think we literally just answered that
oh i saw a cathode durability question
let's go to that one
go down go down go down good technical
question
keep going ah
how are you going to address the cathode
durability and cost environmental impact
trifecta
is this something you're going to leave
the enviro upstream supply chain to
solve no i think we tried to answer that
directly
i mean we really are looking at not just
what happens in the cathode facility but
like currently outside the cathode
facility that should really be inside
and removing processes that shouldn't
have been there in the first place
and the use of reagents that add
are just costly and not necessary and
removing a bunch of white
wastewater from the process guys are
there anything is there anything you you
want to add to
maybe like uh go through everyone like
maybe say what you're doing and you know
say a few words i don't know
sure um i just want to reiterate the
fact that this is a massive problem
massive problem and it seems like
tesla's
on its way and ahead um but we need
everybody's help
um because it's a it's everybody's
planet
and we're not going to get to 20 terror
hours by ourselves
so please think about this carefully um
as it
affects everybody so let's get on it
yeah and and obviously if you care about
uh solving sustainability uh and doing
hardcore engineering
uh definitely come work tesla
yeah we you know we went through a
couple of the manufacturing improvements
uh and you know it kind of looks easy
when you put together a nice slide deck
but
the challenges are like this it's super
challenging when you take
materials out of the process when you
integrate processes
together uh you have to do a lot of
things at once
and that's that's like this immense
engineering challenge
uh and so like
you know to appreciate that like you
need
like to get through this we need like
the best engineers we've got and we've
got this awesome team i just want to
shout out also
to all of our team watching like you
guys are awesome
like you absolutely kicked us putting
this together and
yeah yes thank you
thank you tesla team totally agree
yeah that's it like yeah yeah
rodney westmoreland uh managing the
construction here at tesla
um what i would like to say is uh one
shout out to the team the team has been
working effortlessly a very very tough
um project here for 24 hours a day it
seems like
around the clock to have this complete
the thing that sets us apart from a lot
of other construction yeah we have a
construction company here
the thing that sets us apart is that
we're integrated in the
manufacturing process so every detail
that comes from drew's mouth is directly
implicated into the system that we're
that we're building um
that way it what would typically take
three or four months to create a
specification
our design team is working right with
the manufacturing team uh to allow us to
speed that process up tremendously so
yeah it's definitely
a a important part of the vertically
integrated approach is to be able to
design the factory around the equipment
in fact together with the equipment so
that you can build the factory at lower
cost and
and more quickly yeah i'm scott
i focus on cell design i i think
it's hard to put into words how
inspiring this is i've been at it for a
long time with tesla
and um yeah i really hope others have
joined us since when it's gone it's
2005.
yes with many of you um but thank you
um you know it
yeah you're before drew but who's
keeping track
um but i'm really stoked what the team's
been able to accomplish over the last
you know
short period of time about a year it's
been really an incredible transformation
i mean hopefully what we've shown you
inspires you to join us or join somebody
else in the effort
and i couldn't think of a greater more
intelligent more hardworking team to be
working on with this problem
hi peter i lead the manufacturing
improvement team
and i guess the point that i would like
to make is
[Music]
manufacturing improvements is like the
accelerator
so like you think about the execution
that rodney talked about
in terms of how fast we've been able to
put together this factory
which is amazing and something that's
been really
incredible to be a part of that's not
enough what we need to do is improve the
manufacturing technology that's the real
accelerator
and that's what we're really focused on
elon talks about it all the time that
really going and improving that system
is what will enable us to
get to the scale and the cost that we
need and then the other point that i
would make is on the recruiting side
like it doesn't matter if you know about
batteries
if you come from any industry you can
you can do something fantastic in the in
the work that we're doing
we talk to people from industries that
you wouldn't imagine like i talked to a
guy from
who makes golf balls and he has stuff
which is really impactful for what we're
doing so
you know if you're in any industry and
you want to be you know impactful here
like
come join us it'd be great
hi um excuse me hi i'm tony i've been
working in
um lithium and cathode materials for
almost 23 years now and this is the most
growth i've seen
in a company i've been here a little
over a year and a half
um we're hiring amazing people
that are allowing us to leverage
technology that most of the industry
is struggling to to achieve so to answer
the question how are we going to do this
we are really advancing the materials
manufacturing for cathodes
and for lithium beyond uh what has been
accomplished
in the previous 20 years
it's exciting
yeah my name is turner um work closely
with the team i've worked a lot with
with everyone here and
um on the on the cathode and upstream
materials
side it's it's really important that
everyone understand that
this growth is coming this this growth
is real we are going to make
all of these batteries and everyone
needs to grow
with us the entire supply chain needs to
grow with us and
if you have an idea that simplifies
anything in the supply chain
come talk to us come work with us and
let's do it
any any existing specification is wrong
any existing
manufacturing method is wrong process
equipment it's wrong it's just a
question of how wrong
quote elon musk yes exactly we're wrong
just the question of how wrong
try to be less wrong so tell us how
we're wrong and how we could do it
better so that we can
accelerate and and improve as fast as
possible
all right well i guess uh thank you
everyone for coming i hope you liked the
presentation
uh very exciting future ahead um you
know uh
we're gonna work our damn desk to
transition the world's sustainable
energy as quickly as possible
and your support and help is is key to
that success
so uh thanks again uh super appreciated
um
and look forward to the next event thank
you thank you
[Music]
you